Most of us grow up thinking that the
bond between infant and mother is a very
tight sharing of interests.
However,
in fact if we look at it from the point
of view of the genes that are in the
mother and in the offspring,
we see that there is a strong potential
for evolutionary conflict that has
medical consequences and so I would
like to start this by talking about the
evolutionary theory behind
parent offspring conflict.
We owe that to bill Hamilton who came
up with the idea of cancellation to Bob
Trevor's who saw that that
had implications for parent
offspring conflict and to
David Haig who saw that parent offspring
and mother father conflict both will
have influence on the course of pregnancy.
So the basic idea of kin selection comes
from Bill Hamilton here photographed on
the Amazon River,
a British evolutionary geneticist.
Bill saw that what matters in
evolution is not individual survival,
but the increase in frequency of the
genes that are carried by an individual.
That's an insight he got from Fisher
and Haldane and others therefore pays an
individual to sacrifice itself.
If more copies of that individual's
genes get into the next generation,
then if that individual
did not sacrifice itself.
So there can be a conflict between
genetic interest in individual survival.
The costs and benefits of acts are
weighed against each other in genetic
currency.
Yeah.
And genes exist not only in the
individual but also in its relatives.
Therefore,
if an individual can help its relatives
to survive and reproduce and if the
increase in the number of its genes in
the next generation through offspring of
relatives is greater than the
decrease through its own offspring,
is a consequence of that act than
helping behavior will be selected.
Now, how do we calculate genetic
costs and benefits? Well,
if we let be equal benefit,
that would be the increase
in the recipient's fitness
is as the result of an act.
See,
the cost would be the decrease in the
donor's fitness is the result of an act
are,
is the coefficient of relationship,
which is the probability that a gene in
the donor and a gene and the recipient
are identical by descent
from a common ancestor.
Yeah.
Given that the condition for helping is
that B divided by c is greater than one
divided by r or there'd be times R is
greater than c times one or to put it into
English.
The increase in the relatives fitness
as a result of the act times the
relationship to the relative.
So that's B Times r is greater than the
decrease in the donor's is a result of
the act times its relationship to itself.
It's relationship to itself is one.
Yeah,
so some of the kinds of traits that are
proposed as instances of Ken selected
quote,
all through wisdom of acting to save
others that are costing yourself include
alarm calls in birds,
ground squirrels and primates
guarding behavior and vigilance,
helping at the nest in birds,
suppressed reproduction which we see
and bees and wasps and ants in social
carnivores like mere cats.
Wild dogs dwarf mongooses and
hyenas and they could mole rats.
Here we see some mere
cats confronting a cobra.
They have both suppressed reproduction
with one female reproducing and the rest
helping and they have guarding
behavior and vigilance.
Now there are alternative explanations
for some of these behaviors,
but these are the kinds of things that
behavioral ecologist explain his kin
selected.
Now the next idea is that of parent
offspring conflict, which we get from Bob.
Trevor's
apparent in a diploid sexually reproducing
species is 50% related to each of its
offspring,
and that means it would like to invest
equally in each of its offspring.
However,
the offspring is 100% related to itself.
It's 50% related to its full sibs
and it's 25% related to half sibs.
Therefore,
an offspring should,
should try to get more investment from
its parents than its parents had been
selected to give. That's that difference
between a hundred percent and 50%
okay.
The offspring should seek to force the
parental investment upwards until it's
inclusive fitness.
It's own fitness plus what it would get
from current or potential siblings is
maximized.
It doesn't try to take everything,
but it tries to take more
than the parent wants to give.
Yeah,
so parent and offspring are expected
to disagree over how long the period of
parental investment should be over the
amount of parental investments should be
given and over the altruistic or
selfish behavior of offspring towards
relatives.
Yeah,
parent offspring conflict is expected
increase during the period of parental
care and offspring are expected to
employee both biological and psychological
weapons in conflict with their parents.
The next step in this train of reasoning
came from David Haig who thought about
parent offspring conflict in pregnancy.
As with any,
oh,
an offspring that's the fetus is selected
to extract more from the mother than
the mother is selected to give and we've
seen from our study of invasiveness
that fetal tissue in the
placenta is put into itself,
into a position to manipulate maternal
physiology and it can do that by hormone
production.
That kind of manipulation is easier
when the fetal tissue has invaded the
maternal tissue in the placenta and
there are two with two main ways of doing
that. One is to increase maternal blood
pressure that continues the risk for
Preeclampsia and the other is to increase
the sugar concentration of maternal
blood that leads to
pregnancy related diabetes.
Yeah.
This kind of control is
related to genetic imprinting.
Genes are imprinted or turned
off by methylating the DNA,
we're changing the acetylation
pattern in histones.
Some genes are imprinted differently in
the germ line of fathers and mothers.
This is called parent of
origin or genomic imprinting.
Genes imprinted in the germ line are
not expressed early in fetal development
and they are then reprogrammed in the
germ line of the adult to be appropriate
for being either a mother or father.
Okay. Either a male or a female.
There is a connection between kin
selection and genomic imprinting.
The mother is 50% related to each year
for her offspring as we have emphasized,
but if she has future
offspring with other males,
then only this offspring is
50% related to the father.
The others will not be
related to him at all.
Yeah.
Thus to the degree that
meeting is polygamous.
Paternal genes are going to be selected
to extract more from the mother than the
mother is selected to give and the mother
or the maternal genes will be selected
to resist.
So to develop that idea
in a bit more detail.
What's going on is that the father is
turning off genes that downregulate
growth, so paternally expressed
transcripts, enhanced growth.
There's an interesting double negative
here. Let me run through it again.
The father is turning off genes that
downregulate growth paternally expressed
transcripts,
enhance growth.
The mother is turning off
genes that upregulate growth,
so maternally express
transcripts inhibit growth.
The normal state of the embryo is that
there is an equilibrium in which both
mother and offspring are in
reasonably good condition.
Yeah.
However,
the conflict is revealed when the action
taken by one parent is canceled by
disrupting the imprinting
in mice.
This can be done with extended with a
genetic manipulation and that produces an
increase or decrease of about
10% in birth weight. In humans,
we rely on mutations that
produced rare diseases.
We'll talk more about that later.
Yeah.
The idea is well supported for the jeans,
Igf two and Igf two r this is insulin
like growth factor and its receptor CDK
nic and GRB 10 but there's not yet.
We'll support it for others genes that
are known to be imprinted by sex of
origin.
So to summarize,
natural selection acts to
increase the frequency of genes,
not the survival of individuals.
Genes can influence their fate by
influencing actions that affect the
reproductive success of relatives.
Okay.
Parent and offspring are in conflict
over reproductive investment.
The offspring is selected to demand more
than the period of selected to give.
Okay.
Maternally and fraternity derived genes
are in similar conflict within the,
within the offspring.
And this seems to explain
genomic imprinting that is
parent of origin in pretty,
in both cases,
the normal condition is an equilibrium
established by an evolutionary tug of war.
Disrupting that equilibrium can
manifest in unselected pathology.